[Musique]
tous les habitants peuvent recevoir une
aide humanitaire ils doivent d'abord
s'enregistrer au guichet comme ici sur
le comptoir bien en évidence une copie
de l'ordre qui vient de Kiev évacuation
générale il y a aussi des informations
sur les transports gratuits et un
formulaire pour ceux qui veulent rester
c'est obligatoire de le remplir ce n'est
pas obligatoire mais c'est recommandé
comme ça les autorités savent qu'elle
est là
choisi de partir mais elle n'a pas
réussi à convaincre sa mère de la suivre
bon écoutez dites-lui qu'elle pourra
toujours appeler ses numéros pour le
transport au cas où elle change d'avis
elle ne voudra jamais aller là-bas mais
merci quand même
je me sens très mal mais je ne peux rien
faire je ne veux pas rester ici
c'est trop dangereux
[Musique]
j'ai des petits enfants et je veux les
voir grandir
les derniers habitants restants non pour
la plupart pas l'intention de partir
notre boulot
c'est de
Vevey va être très dur
le moment
tout le monde n'est pas convaincu
selon la Constitution personne n'a le
droit de nous forcer à évacuer c'est à
nous de choisir l'armée
ukrainienne est en ville il nous
protégeront
environ un quart de la population
d'avant guerre est toujours à cramatork
des abris antibromes sont maintenus en
service par la mairie certains y vivent
désormais de manière permanente
je vais quand même vérifier en partant
qu'ils ont bien dégagé la sortie de
secours comme ça si jamais Dieu nous en
garde quelque chose se passe il y a
toujours une sortie de secours pour
évacuer
en sous-sol les jeunes suivent leur
cours en ligne y compris les ateliers
sportifs
c'est mieux ou c'est moins bien la
classe à distance
mon fils ne reste jamais assis il va
s'allonger avec sa tablette
mais il en faudrait plus pour que Tania
se décide à
évacuerait-il où dormir est temps sur
des matelas même le sol dans une salle
de sport non merci
[Musique]
au Lexis et Misco a une mission
paradoxale il doit à la fois rassurer
les habitants sur la sécurité des abris
et en même temps leur suggérait de
partir pourquoi ne pas évacuer vers
copenitski
je ne veux pas partir ici c'est chez moi
et de toute façon il y a des
bombardements partout alors
quelle serait la goutte d'eau la chose
qui vous prédire
ça y est c'est bon je quitte la ville
qui fait que vous nous laisseriez même
juste temporairement vous emmener
ailleurs raté pour cette fois
mais au Lexy à sa petite idée sur ce que
pourrait être la goutte d'eau
quand les températures vont chuter en
dessous de zéro là je pense qu'ils vont
gentiment faire leur sac et accepter
d'évacuer parce qu'ils ne pourront pas
chauffer
les entreprises de distribution d'eau et
d'énergie vidanges les canalisations en
prévision du gel une partie du système
d'approvisionnement en gaz a été
détruite par les Russes ou se retrouve
sous leur contrôle les habitants
pourraient passer l'hiver sans chauffage
c'est la raison principale qui pousse
les autorités à évacuer les populations
les départs vers l'ouest ont lieu ici à
la gare ferroviaire de pokrovsk mais
dans ce train les passagers fuient plus
les combats que le froid
on a peur pour nos enfants
peut-être que là où on va se sera mieux
qu'ici ça ne sert à rien de rester à
attendre que notre maison soit bombardée
c'est d'ailleurs précisément ce qui est
arrivé à André
j'ai quitté ma maison a été fracassée
c'était avant-hier pendant la nuit
j'étais en train de dormir une requête
est tombée pas loin et a explosé toutes
les fenêtres la porte et même le toit
avant ça je ne vais pas évacuer parce
que merci
parce que je pensais que la guerre
allait se terminer rapidement
sympathisé avec cette famille de bac
mouth l'une des villes les plus durement
touchées du don-basse
il est presque 4h du matin quand le
train entre en guerre de croppy vinitzky
dans le centre du pays mais le voyage
n'est pas fini il reste 30 km à
parcourir en bus pour gagner ce village
à l'arrivée des travailleurs municipaux
se chargent de l'accueil
avec le soutien financier du
gouvernement les villages de la région
mettent des bâtiments à disposition des
populations évacuées
ça ira pour l'instant c'était ok c'est
ok c'est mieux que le boum boum on est
mieux ici que sous les bombes bien sûr
et après bah après on va continuer à
vivre voilà